ce vin a consommé bien sûr avec
modération n'est pas tout à fait comme
les autres il est produit par des
étudiants viticulteurs au cœur des Côtes
de Gascogne aujourd'hui s'il est
présenté au Potager du Roi à Versailles
c'est pour convaincre les amateurs de
saveurs foie gras du Périgord fromage
fermier de Bourgogne mais aussi bière de
Douai le terroirsto regroupe 11
exploitations de lycée agricole qui font
le tour de France à la conquête de
palais curieux on cherche un petit filet
pour des amis et donc on a un petit
assortiment de terrine de rillettes etc
et voilà on a trouvé ça sympa et
apparemment c'est des jeunes qui
essayent de développer des activités
dans les lycées tout simple c'est bien
c'est un gage de qualité peut-être
les amateurs de produits made in France
rencontrent ainsi les producteurs de
demain ceux qui ont le souci de la
qualité et surtout qui portent les
valeurs de leur région on essaie
d'expliquer notre gamme tous nos
produits puis nos traditions et notre
culture de la Gascogne
sud-ouest entre autres tout ce qui va
être
tradition familiale le terroir c'est
très rural notre notre région puis les
fêtes du Sud-Ouest également faire vivre
la tradition et participer à un exercice
pédagogique à taille réelle le but c'est
que les étudiants voient toute la
filière de la fabrication à la
commercialisation donc ce qui permet aux
étudiants plus tard de dire bah tiens
quand je veux m'installer qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire
l'occasion donc pour les étudiants
d'avoir un premier aperçu de leur future
vie professionnelle